the animal
control by law is being changed because
we're trying to put in
a bit of harsher restrictions on people
that we have
consistent problems with so the old
bylaw
is quite vague we're changing things
like
people need unimpeded access to their
front door or a
door to their dwelling and this is for
safety issues that we've run across
such as service workers
council employees have been attacked by
dogs postal workers things of that
nature
what we're finding right now is a lot of
our dog enforcement officers are
spending most of their time dealing with
problems
and so they're enforcing constantly and
they don't get the chance to educate the
public
so our hope is with a stronger bylaw
that we can enforce their infringements
and other actions
we can get the public and the people
that are a problem to be taken care of
as quickly as possible
so i think what's really important for
us to get across to people is these
stronger bylaws are not punishing the
people who are good dog owners
the majority of dog owners in
invercargill are extremely responsible
people
and they're very caring for their pets
and they're also very conscious of their
neighbors and citizens within
invercargill
the bylaws are really getting
strengthened to deal with the problem
issues that we have or maybe repeat
offenders
if we have stronger bylaws it allows us
to enforce
without having to spend lots of time on
it it just cuts the problem out and it
gives the dog officers
more time to spend doing the more
positive things of their roles
people are really surprised to find out
that we average
one dog for every five people in
invercargill that's a statistic that's
actually extremely high
and that's what we know as far as
registered dogs we estimate that there's
another 900 to 1000 dogs that aren't
registered which would bring that
average up
so because of that we have to have
strong enough bylaws in place so when
there is a problem we can deal with it
as quickly as possible
so some of our key changes that we are
doing in the new bylaw
are we would like that all dogs
registered as menacing
are neutered within 30 days of receiving
that notification
that means that after they've gone if
the owner decides to appeal
and if they failed the appeal within 30
days that dog would have to be neutered
currently that is not in the bylaw we're
also asking that all
dogs that are registered as dangerous
must be neutered within 30 days of that
classification as well
um other things that we're changing is
we're defining
under control as being on a lead
so whereas before we actually never
defined what under control means we are
looking at possibly adding
through the submission process under
control being a voice command as well
because some dogs do respond
differently to voice command than they
do on lead
we're also including maps that will give
a defined area of where you can have
your dog
off a leash because previously it's been
a bit confusing so we were thinking by
providing full color maps people have a
really
good idea of where they're allowed to
have their dog off lead
a lot of people don't understand where
they can actually have the dog on and
off lead
like queen's park is a great example you
actually need to have your dog on lead
but it's also the things we want to
clarify in the bylaw and
within the policy are for people who are
non-dog owners as well
so another major change that we've made
is we're saying that
you cannot have a dog that intimidates
people at your gate
for example if you're a citizen walking
down the street whether you're a dog
owner or a non-dog owner
if you are constantly being having a dog
aggressively
go at you at that fence and it becomes a
problem and it's a repeated problem
amongst
more than one person it's not an obvious
complaint by somebody who just doesn't
like your dog
then we've put that in that we will
actually take actions to ask you to
either move your gate back
or to do things put things in place that
will help
make it less of a problem because one of
the things we found
is that we don't really have any powers
to change the problems and what we want
to do through our new model is called
evade so our first step would be to
educate people
so in that situation our first step
would be to go talk to the owner
say look there's been a problem there's
multiple reports we would really like to
work with you to fix it
before we would start writing
infringement notices or sending out
warnings
so under control in a vehicle to us is
means that the dog is actually tied up
properly
or put in the car with enough air but
cannot be released from the vehicle
or it needs to be kept in a kennel in
the back of the vehicle or in a truck it
actually needs to be restrained within a
kennel
it can't be just sitting in the back
free and that's also for the dog safety
not just people safety because if you
stop suddenly
or you were to have an accident in your
car and your dog isn't properly kindled
in the back of your truck
obviously the dog could be victim to
that accident in our current bylaw
you can have three dogs and then you
don't need a license to get a
then you'll need a license to get a
fourth dog in the new bylaw you will
have two dogs
and you will need a license to get a
third some people are a little bit
confused about that
so we have a grandfathering enroll so if
you currently
have three dogs that will not affect you
when you register your dogs you'll be
under the same registration system as
you were before
however if you have two dogs and you're
getting a third dog after july
you will have to apply for the special
license fee
also if you say have three dogs now
and you're registering all three in july
but maybe one dies in a year or two
or or something happens and you get a
third dog again
then you will have to apply under the
new system so the submission process has
been open
from the 5th of april and it goes until
the 8th of may
for the submissions we've gone out to
the invercargill city dog park
which is over in south city and we set
up for a day with one of our dog control
officers and we were answering questions
to anyone that had
issues or wanted to find out more
information
so all you need to do is get a
submission form you can get it printed
out on the invicargo city council
website
or you can go into one of the invicargo
city buildings so you can get it from
the library
the esk street building or in bluff at
the community center
once you fill out your submission you
just return it
you can either send it in by post or you
can bring it in by hand
you can also email your submission in
once we receive them we will go through
them
we will be making modifications based on
the submissions if we get a lot of
issues
that we find are really relevant to a
great number of people then we look at
changing those before we send the final
one through
it will go to council you'll have the
opportunity to present to them
and once you do that then we make those
changes based on what council is heard
so what's going to happen is once the
changes go through everything will be
effective for the next financial year
so basically with your index dog
registration those changes will be
implemented
you